welcome in welcome welcome everybody out
there i am dion robowen a reporter for
the wall street journal this is market
takes i want to thank everybody so much
for for being here with me on the
youtube channel we are doing a very
special edition of market takes for you
today uh this is a live stream we are
coming to you uh just an hour and a half
or about half an hour actually after fed
chair jerome powell finished his press
conference a couple hours after the fed
dropped its statement one of the most
consequential fed meetings in quite some
time we just finished up markets have
now closed for the day we are going to
talk about what the market thought about
the fed we are going to talk about what
fed chair jerome powell said we are
going to talk about the the economy and
the potential economic ramifications of
this fed decision we are going to break
all that down and talk about all that um
i know you could have been anywhere in
the world but you're here with me and i
want to thank you so much for doing that
we are diving all the way in to the fomc
meeting today the fed chair jerome
powell press conference and the market
reaction we are going to do all of that
starting right now so look let's take a
look right now at the stock market and
how markets reacted markets just closing
um just a bit about a minute ago here in
the u.s uh new york the dow ending up
about one percent the s p 500 up about
one and a half percent the nasdaq up
about two and a half percent uh if you
saw right as the uh the fed statement
was released the market did not have a
positive reaction the dow basically
going straight down but we saw a
complete reversal of that after fed
chair jerome powell started talking i'm
going to talk about what happened what
we saw and why that was
now first let's let's take a step back
here and talk about how we got here and
the news of the day coming into this
meeting now last week we had a another
one of these special sessions where i
jumped on after the cpi the consumer
price index report and i said to all you
guys this report is a game changer
anything that you would thought coming
into this report throw it out the game
plan light it on fire throw it in the
trash can and and the fed really did
that now the market had been pricing in
a 50 basis point rate hike that means
the fed was expected to raise rates
twice as fast as it normally does
you saw around the end of last week
market expectations change
i think a lot of that was due to a
report from wsj's very own nick timaros
i had a report that the fed was
rethinking that 50-point base that 50
basis point rate hike that they had
baked into the cake last month coming
into this month because of that cpi
report we're going to be raising three
times as fast as normal at this meeting
and that's exactly what they did so we
got a 75 basis point rate hike like i
said triple the normal pace the fed
raises rates at and has historically
done the biggest rate increase since
1994. so today was a big deal but that
was all priced in the market had
expected that coming in and what really
we want to dive into is what we heard
from the chairman what we saw from the
market's reaction to that and what that
means going forward so look let's dive
in
remember that cpi report showed
inflation coming in at 8.6 percent last
month
that was higher than point five percent
which was in march where we saw we were
supposed to have peaked the idea was the
fed told us well inflation peaked in
march it's gonna start coming down
slowly but you know we're gonna get
there back to our two percent target
well may was higher than that and so now
we're we're back to square one basically
so then after that in addition to that
cpi report
we got the inverted yield curve
overnight coming into today the 210
yield curve which is a long time
predictive recession do you go check out
my uh my video on that we did a video on
that a couple months ago on why the 210
yield curve is such a great predictor of
recessions we get into and explain all
of that but
that yield curve basically inverted
overnight you saw the three-year yield
well above the 10-year yield and the
three-year yield well above the 30-year
yield which means if you're an investor
you're getting paid more to loan the
government money for three years then
you are getting paid to loan the
government money for 30 years that's
just incredible and again these are
things that predict a recession because
it suggests that the money the value of
money or the need for money now is much
greater than need for money in the
future that tends to say that investors
are bearish there's worries about
recession
you also got the atlanta fed's gdp now
report suggesting that we are going to
get zero percent growth in the second
quarter of this year that's what we're
in right now if we get zero percent
growth or if we get below that zero
percent growth even point zero one
percent that basically puts the us in
recession because we had negative growth
in the first quarter so today's meeting
was a big time meeting and fed chair
jerome powell i don't know if he rose to
the moment look the stock market really
liked what he had to say like i said the
nasdaq up two and a half percent i think
the key to that was what the chair said
uh when asked about really the fed's
priorities he said we need to show
resolve as in in the face of inflation
we need to show resolve get inflation
back down but
we also need to be flexible
well flexible means that maybe we're not
on automatic pilot maybe rates aren't
going to continue to go up by 75 basis
points each meeting maybe the fed is not
determined to do whatever it takes and
look i really think today's meeting was
a chance for fed chair jerome powell's
whatever it takes moment on inflation uh
when we had the kovid 19 you know
lockdowns and economic shutdown fed
chair jerome powell came out and very
strongly said look we're going to do
what it takes for as long as it takes if
that means 120 billion dollars a month
getting pumped into the economy rates
down low negative real rates for a long
time we will do this for as long as
necessary and made it clear that we will
do what it takes for as long as it takes
i thought today's meeting required a
similar response from the fed chair and
it didn't feel like we got it he said
the right things he said the words
inflation's their top priority we need
to show resolve we've got to get market
prices under control but there was no
you know what i really would have
thought the fed chair would do here is
is kind of turned directly to the camera
he had a very long speech today and he
spoke for a while before he took
questions and i really thought he would
have taken a chance to kind of look at
the american people and say
we will do whatever it takes to get
inflation under control we have got this
we are going to use all of our tools and
we are going to get inflation under
control and we are going to get it under
control quickly as fast as we can they
love that word expeditiously we're gonna
get inflation under control
expeditiously and i really felt like the
fed chair didn't do that today and it's
interesting to see why he didn't he also
sort of again hedged said we're going to
be flexible we're going to be nimble
we're going to be you know if inflation
isn't really wilding out of control
we're going to be flexible and maybe go
back down to 50 basis points maybe even
25 basis points maybe even stop raising
rates right
so they they raise their projections
they lower their projections for the
economic growth raised projections for
inflation but there wasn't a moment for
me where fed chair jerome powell looked
in the camera and said america we got
this and i feel like that's what was
needed today so anyway you saw the mark
the reaction throughout the markets
bonds coming down stocks rising high the
dollar falling down again i think a lot
of that was just in reaction to the move
that we've seen since that cpi report
last week uh bond yields have just gone
absolutely through the roof you had the
10-year yield going up to 3.5
that's the highest it's been in a long
long long time uh and and i think today
was just a bit of a relief rally a lot
of folks saying okay the fed is is
willing to be flexible willing to be
nimble they're not dogmatic about
raising rates well it's time to buy
because things aren't the worst case
scenario and i think that's what we saw
look let's get into a little bit of the
difference between the june and the may
uh statements the biggest difference
between the statements was the committee
said that it is strongly committed to
returning inflation to its two percent
objective uh and replaced the phrase
with appropriate firming in the stance
of monetary policy right it was a small
a small change but
they're saying that we are strongly
committed to firming the stance of
monetary policy and i thought that was
probably the biggest change in the
statement that we saw in between last
month and this month uh strongly
committed to returning inflation to its
two percent objective again it's there
it's in the statement it's in black and
white you can't deny that they said it
they did say it but you didn't see the
fed chair come out and kind of bang the
table and say we're gonna do this and
take it under control
interesting note esther george a long
time hawk uh hawks meaning folks who
like rates higher because they're more
worried about inflation was the one
person to descent on the 75 basis point
rate hike she has long been known as you
know when the fed was cutting rates she
dissented when the fed wanted to hold
instead of raise she dissented this has
been her thing for a very long time and
today esther george dissented and said
no no i think we should only raise by 50
basis points personally i think she's
trolling the committee and trolling fed
chair jerome powell ahead of her
retirement that's just me it's one man's
impression
don't take me too seriously uh the
summary of economic projections another
big piece of this like i said they they
raised their expectations for rate hikes
previously the fed was saying we're
gonna get rates up to about two and a
half to three percent by the end of the
year now saying we're gonna get rates up
to about three percent every voter on
the committee said that rates will be at
least three percent by the end of the
year five voters see rates above three
and a half percent in 2022
in 2023 every single person on the
committee saw rates above three and a
half percent again this is meaningfully
higher than rates were projected to be
the last time the fed released summary
of economic projections what that means
higher interest rates higher rates on a
mortgage higher rates on borrowing for a
car higher rates on your credit card all
those things are going up if you've got
a home equity line a credit or a home
equity yeah a home equity line of credit
not a loan because you got that in one
installment but if you've got a home
equity line of credit the rate that you
were paying yesterday is not the rate
you're paying today that rate has gone
up by 75 basis points and the projection
is that these rates are going to stay
higher for a longer period of time
you had five voters actually saying they
expected the rates to be above four
percent uh
in next year so that's saying rates are
going to be higher for longer and more
of the committee saying that they
projected that
the fed seeing
uh the u.s jobless rate now this was on
the other side of that they expect a
higher unemployment rate this year and
next year and into 2024 the unemployment
rate remaining about four percent so the
fed again saying they project that
soft-ish landing where we are going to
see job losses we are going to see folks
lose their job we are going to see more
layoffs and firings but
not at a large scale and again
unemployment will remain at those very
low levels three point seven to four
percent through 2024 and fed fed policy
makers said they expect to cut rates in
2024
um i think the biggest thing from the
the actual press conference right
because you get the statement it comes
out and then fed chair jerome powell
comes out and defends and explains the
statement
really i thought what powell said about
the us economy and the consumer again
giving that we've seen today u.s retail
sales coming in negative negative point
three percent last month while inflation
rose one percent last month so prices
rose by one percent but overall spending
declined by 0.3 that means you're seeing
a significant pullback of american
consumers despite that and despite the
atlanta fed's gdp now measure which is
again it's the federal reserve's own
measure of expected gdp for the second
quarter that came in at zero after
negative one percent in the first
quarter fed chair jerome powell still
saying that the u.s economy is strong
and that the consumer is doing well
that's not what the numbers today told
us and again he's been in a meeting all
day you got to give him that uh but
that is clearly not what the numbers
told us and fed chair powell coming out
and just saying hey you know what things
are good still trying to reassure us the
economy is strong the consumer is doing
well i thought that was very interesting
and certainly a point that i took away
watching from that meeting so again this
is our live stream market takes thank
everybody who's tuning in right now with
us on the live stream on youtube really
appreciate you guys for tuning in right
now we are continuing talking about what
we learned from fed chair jerome powell
from the summary of economic projections
and from the fed and the market's
reaction look another thing that i think
may have flown under the radar given the
market's reaction was powell's continued
use of the word restrictive when talking
about monetary policy restrictive policy
means policy that's so high where
interest rates are high enough that they
restrict the economy from growth that
you were trying to reign in demand and
they had really shied away from using
that word they only kind of accepted
using it here and there last month at
the last policy meaning you saw fed
share pal kind of pepper it in there say
okay yeah we might get to restricted
levels today restrictive restrictive
restrictive we are raising monetary
policy to restrictive levels we are
going to be you know monetary policy is
going to be restrictive going forward
again
he said that but he also said but we're
flexible you know we and the market
really liked flexible so i think there
was a lot of restrictive and a little
bit of flexible and the market really
chose to focus on flexible i think that
was probably the biggest or my biggest
takeaway at least from this meeting now
what to watch for in the minutes that
are coming out on july 6. we're going to
get minutes from this meeting we may
find out why esther george dissented we
may find out whether this was really you
know everybody was on board with this 75
basis point hike again three times the
rate that they normally raise rates at
was everybody on board was there a lot
of disagreement what did the federal
reserve really say about this the fomc
uh the policy making committee how on
board was everybody what were some of
their worries what were some of the
concerns and what were the things that
were said to get everybody moved from 50
basis points which is what they said
they were going to do last month to 75
which is a significant increase for the
economy
clearly
the big the biggest takeaway if you're
gonna step back away from this just
looking at this meeting right coming
into this meeting i think the biggest
takeaway was that investors believe and
trust the fed to do exactly what they
say they're gonna do which is have a
soft landing slow demand but really
allow the economy to continue growing
and not reduce policy so much that they
can bring in inflation and they can
continue to keep the economy on track if
you look at 5-year 10-year 30-year
break-even rates those all declined
after we got that cpi report last week
on june 10th those are investor
expectations of the economy and again
investors are betting real money on
these expectations those all came in and
showed that investors expect longer term
inflation is going to come down but if
you look at the treasury market that's
also investors and those yields jumped
through the roof jumping about 40 50
basis points in just the last couple
days those are historic size moves
so investors are saying long term we
think that inflation is going to remain
in control that the fed has this under
control and they're going to keep
inflation down and near that two percent
target but if you look at the real
economy if you look at what what's
happening with consumers what's
happening with companies uh prices
continue to rise higher and we see that
you know wages wage increases are still
running at five percent those are
increased uh ppi producer prices that
came in nearly 11
we just got that report yesterday so
we're also seeing consumers expectation
of inflation rise to new highs we saw
the university of michigan's consumer
sentiment survey said the public's
expectation of inflation five years from
now jumped to 3.3 percent that's up from
where it was in may and inflation a year
ago jumped to 5.4 percent up from its
previous levels as well uh the new york
fed's inflation expectations also
jumping to point six percent uh so these
numbers and again even the three year
inflation expectation jumping to three
point nine percent near four percent
this shows that consumers businesses do
not believe that longer term inflation
expectations are going to be rained in
they don't trust the fed to be able to
do what they've said they're going to do
and that's a concern that i don't think
fed chair jerome powell really hit as
hard as i think he needed to hit it
today so that's that's definitely big
and and i think will be one of the big
takeaways as we move forward throughout
the rest of this year as we look back on
this meeting
hey look i am dion robon this has been
our very special
market take session looking at the
federal reserves meeting today and and
can they tame inflation can the fed tame
inflation that's the big question
clearly the market still has confidence
in the fed you saw it with what happened
in the bond market what happened in the
stock market what we're seeing in some
of these more complex markets like break
evens and tips and things like that but
the consumer and business owners that
looks to be a different story and we are
seeing continued disbelief continue to
higher inflation expectations and that
was actually one thing that fed chair
jerome powell pointed out himself he
said we saw these numbers in the
university of michigan
consumer sentiment index and that
worried us that was one of the reasons
that we raised rates by as much as we
did so keep an eye on those inflation
expectations from consumers obviously
the feds watching i'll be watching i
hope you'll continue watching those and
i hope you'll continue to watch what
we've got going on right here on market
takes a little bit of shameless
self-promotion but i appreciate y'all
tuning in with me anyway we're gonna
wrap that up here
um i will be back with you guys for a
regularly scheduled edition of market
takes next week we will not be on on
monday that is juneteenth brand new
federal holiday the wsj workers get the
day off so i will not be with you on
monday but we will continue to do this
live stream going forward i hope you'll
tune in and be with us there i'm dionne
robowen for the wall street journal
thank you for tuning in to market takes
and i hope you'll stick with us and come
back again